I smell a little [ __ ]
guys watch this huh watch this huh yeah
this is what you've all been complaining
about what the [ __ ] just happened is
that you can't see anything and oh he
has a betta posture he's just staring at
the ground no I haven't the field of
view has been all messed up I fixed it
oh look at that lamp you're mine I
control this oh hey come here yeah
that's what I'm talking about that's
what I'm thinking titty squishing
talking about come here yeah
all right cool now we can play the game
for real have the three episodes thanks
for being so patient
drugs feel good I feel fine though hey
hey all right hopefully my camera
doesn't freeze that's my only concern
right now diarrhea
oh by Dean Oh same thing also obviously
I'm gonna look at the ground that's
where all the items are just so we're
clear gamers just stop it come here just
so we're clear but now I'm looking up
look there's so much up here look at the
time
look there's oh oh look how look how
easy it is for me to reach because I'm
so tall look at that look how easy it is
to reach I cuz I'm still tall thank you
bet you tiny little midgets have trouble
not that there's anything wrong being a
tiny little okay
is it batter let me know maybe it's
worse I don't even know okay
alright we got it a little little snack
there's snacks everywhere in this game
ooh okay I like that hello toilet paper
finally we can survive the virus hey
guys
present though well I was not back for
us
whoa oh oh oh come here come here quick
we come here
[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
yeah yeah well did I hit the stop record
or something I'm so paranoid now we're
again
don't eat it oh I catch them every time
oh no mr. chair what'd they do to you
dude that's nasty all right all right
let's get rid of toilet paper I'm gonna
need a lot of it if I'm gonna make it
out of this virus here we go
oh never mind never mind yeah yeah
strong what does that maybe they want to
drink you want to drink that's
disgusting I don't like that at all
come here what's beeping am i beeping
airs at you guys hello stop oh my god oh
all right what do we have here I'm
looking at we don't need toilet paper
obviously hello soap have ever
ain't so bad Oh found you
yeah lamp more like name yeah I know
insults alright so they're dead
it's supposed to be jump down there huh
safe landing every time I'm good at this
I know what I'm doing I did not badly
not register I wish a tweak that a
little bit cuz it's like it shouldn't be
that hard to just throw it off your oh
why we're really low and healthful up I
guess another thing is that wow I don't
have anything the menu your arms are
kind of like this length that's why I
look down a lot more it's not like I
look at the menu like this okay so like
all right you know what I mean don't be
hating that's why I'm saying don't be
hate it or else or else or else so I'm
not allowed to look down okay alright
I'm just kidding oh damn I'm good at
this game damn I'm good at this game
anyone want some oh I bet we need that's
a lot of ammo we should try and get in
here hello
oh yeah dude that is so nice yeah
all right [ __ ] hey eh eh eh
[ __ ] let go make over the ball
drop the ball drop the ball I said drop
the ball give it to me give it to me
give it a fire ball
you'll pay for this
sorry that's my whatsapp keep forgetting
I can't chick stuff in real life
give me the ball give me the ball
I'm done being nice cop yeah yeah you
like that yeah yeah yeah
you give me to me give it alright I'm
now you're really pissing me off
okay no you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] with
me again ah [ __ ] you what all right you
understand what does this do yeah yeah
Toomas fear you want tomorrow at
transferrin no more games can I shoot
those
that takes a lot of animal there better
be something here are you kidding me are
you kidding me come on give me something
oh man man oh hey man man let me go
bleech please I know your milk I don't
care about milk
oh I knew it
[ __ ] oh my god that was toilet
paper insane H my love me too
don't worry we're gonna get out of here
we'll get out of here together
oh my god alright alright bleach I want
you to look at this I want you to see me
there's this do you understand you betta
you like that bleach give it to me
squeeze two arm and trigger shut up
setec oh those are big dole bleach save
the day you [ __ ] useless
yeah Oh another one
we're now time god damn that's
disgusting
Oh more whoa
where's bleach Thanks
let go let go
thank you where's bleach bleach no smell
like this now like this are you kidding
me
all right we're good the fan what I
looked at oh wait huh you looked a fan
for yeah bleach all right we got our
stuff you [ __ ] you namesti
you're nasty huh
you [ __ ] nasty [ __ ] do you
understand all right come on give it to
Daddy that's Trey
that's [ __ ] right that's [ __ ]
right no one says no to me no way what's
cooking in the kitchen mother [ __ ] us
do you think I'm scared all right put
that here nice all right stupid milk
what is this place a milk place huh
stupid thing oh god you're heavy huh
[ __ ] oh that's sorry I'm sorry guys I'm
so sorry I never let me go in an
apocalypse the [ __ ] is this huh what is
this when it's shitty kitchen is this
what kind of non IKEA kitchen milk yeah
who needs you shut the [ __ ] up
I hit the ceiling that's why I shot
goddamnit I'm not afraid of electricity
huh do I look like a kind oh wow shut up
aah
bring it with bleach
where's Bleek huh are you up there huh
you up there who is this batteries when
the mine is gone and you can't go bring
it suck it suck my ass come on come on
come back here come back here I can't
shoot him hi [ __ ]
alright it's fine let's loot first and
then engage
why could I not shoe because I haven't
cocked it [ __ ] where is he
do you want to fight me or not idiot
where you gonna get you I'm gonna get
you bring it I'm gonna get you I'm gonna
get you [ __ ] I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you I'm gonna get you I'm
gonna get you come to Papa don't be
fresh oh god this bed
you can't run but you can't I smell a
little [ __ ] shut up shut the [ __ ] up
shut up shut up shut up
yeah suck it my nut don't make a rap dog
it's a hard what
hetero hetero maybe you can use that as
battery nice feel good about that that
went well
oh my god how AI not figured out they
I'm not crawling underneath there that's
way too much effort
all right so we got electricity and
stuff that's fine more ammo nice that's
why they gave us so much ammo before
people are like Felix you don't find all
the ammo well I was at this point I had
this much em I'm like shut the [ __ ] up I
don't need to find every ammo in the
game to beat the game if you think
that's how you play games and you don't
understand games all right I'm a veteran
all right
you're nothing I climb I climb vending
machines what do you do it's not a
vending machine well you understand the
point and what I'm saying beat it
otherwise you're playing it wrong it's
so annoying when you miss stuff I get it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter you
have to understand you're a backseat
gamer and what you're saying isn't
helpful so eat ass this should work as a
battery right I want my baby I want my
baby I want my little baby where are you
I know she's here I know she's here I
want my baby I'm gonna find her that's
something we're finding that's something
we're fighting for because I'm actually
low on health that's why
hey girl
hey little girl don't be scared
felix is here felix is here he's gonna
take care of you there you are
oh no little one come here hey hey oh
you scared the gun don't worry it's just
me and you here what's your name don't
worry don't worry it's gonna be fine
stop crying yours in safe little Bernie
you're so pretty
sacred by to this world bye bye Bern
[Music]
it tastes good they're burning thank you
I know you would do it and you were a
good one I knew it alright let's go yeah
guys watch this oh it loads right there
come on are you kidding me I'm worried
that my camera's gonna freeze because I
can't just remove it from the screen if
that happens which would be terrible
Terry bad all right it's dark again
no I just haven't hit load oh come on
he wasted a shot the gameplays ruin hope
all right
squish what do we got oh damn this one
is tricky Leakey how do i how would I
possibly do that you just have to spin
it while I do it okay so let's do the
easier ones last
oh wow oh cool
I see it's their way we can spin it so
they're all connect despite all the odds
Hey
just ignore like all the errors say then
just like don't worry about their errors
we all make them we all make them
isn't that right sit down I don't know
if I oh whoa dude your nails look poppin
dude I'm not I'm not falling for that
trap that's a trap waiting to happen all
right Leah and something excuse me
always got needs do nice hello catch
catch it up damn he had a mole - I got
it
no no I said No
nice let's check here my baby oh my girl
Mike hey this is my [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh this is my show me right
damn it's hard it's harder to hit the
thing almost my little girl hey what
should I name you hey don't be scared
hey it's okay tickle wiggle jiggle
wiggle yes it's okay it's okay
you can make another one right yeah
you're so beautiful huh you're so great
hi fight nice that eight don't be nasty
oh look at that
all right here we go
[Music]
what is this I'm so strong so strong I
don't want to take the elevator I want
to blow up I don't want to go boom boom
give me the pan give me the pan give me
the pen no what I didn't god [ __ ]
damn it can I reach it can I may I might
be able to reach it I'm sure we're gonna
go down there later I pulled out a mag
underneath my head
this game sucks since the game is false
yeah the hell I guess we jumped down
here
Oh God Oh God
yeah we are going down aren't we that's
right that's right give me that give me
the pen [ __ ]
give me the pen all right this dangerous
one huh
pen gang banging banging banging it's a
paying game balls of steels I respect it
I respected gang I'm stuck in the door
bang gang [ __ ]
sit the [ __ ] down [ __ ] stop
[ __ ] around
hold up hold up guys I got an
appointment with your ma pang gang with
a bang gang with the book I'm fine I
feel pretty good actually
jump up
present oh it's just for you buddy
special gift pen gang or bring the pen
we bring the pen gang yeah yeah yeah I
wonder if I can break it with my hands
oh that feels good
still can't do it guys
yeah pain gained during the pen damn you
know miss you know I'm saying you know
I'm saying just chicken footage looks
okay right actually I'm not sure if you
see my health bar just realized
you don't matter yeah
yeah I want some challenge dude what's a
[ __ ] challenge alright ah my ankle
bring it ain't afraid of no fool
[ __ ] sit down it's like ah god damn
that feels good
you're mine you're mine I mine all day
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh oh my
god where'd he go
a mine all night
am i nonstop - those diamonds are inside
and I'm on your couch I'm on your mom
I mind my tea
[Music]
yeah bucket gang you're my new hero oh
my god what is this Skyrim
ooh
oh I hear a little scared child Kodomo
ah no Kuni the scar all right I forgot
how you killed these shotguns are the
best right all right you can't hurt me
yeah nice that was smooth do I need nope
put it there that's right it's nice
getting the hang of it it's almost like
carrying around a night like this is
this to me is looking around cuz this
clearly items around I'm not looking for
the [ __ ] Easter eggs and [ __ ] you
know what I mean like that who looks for
Easter eggs like this I bet that you
know I bet this is super lame I bet you
are god damn it's cool come for [ __ ]
sake
register it won't how did they [ __ ] this
up
I'm such an integral [ __ ] part of the
game and I can't do it
alright we're ready to solve the puzzle
sha sha I'm a thinker that's high I'm
just gonna look around a little bit more
I know there that's there but I'm full
literally so all right looks puzzle
that's puzzle gamers
let's bring the pain
huh whoa okay all right all right
oh they're moving they're moving all
right still easy for a big brain of
course that's it that's it a mag all
right I guess I can carry this in my
hand right
all right time to go akima [ __ ] show
Oh [ __ ]
hello [ __ ] oh I hate those I
guess I need your back dirty clean the
smite name dawg I'm not the frame I'm
not afraid honey
that's awesome lightning dogs are like
Lightning McQueen
are you are you gonna come or should I
come
I'll get that later can I shoot him what
the hell can you stop that
oh it's a head now
can't hide anymore [ __ ] goddamn is fast
dang it all better huh come to me I'll
set you free put you there yeah all
right all right all right give me that
no not the [ __ ] chair you're pathetic
what's that a long time ago you were a
legend
well it ain't now is it when you ain't
now are ya huh look at you
barely a chair look at you you're
nothing
pathetic
how did we get all right
ah all right you want to drop an a down
there cuz oh I look nice yeah I know I
don't use burst-fire but whatever oh
maybe I use it now for the boss which
button isn't it's not the button for the
best for you which button would it be
how do i I don't know how to switch to
burst fire alright so we gotta get his
battery when we came here there's
nothing in the venn or he escaped but
there must be somewhere we can go where
would that be
unless we're supposed to fight him out
here which would I can't hear anything
hello-o cable no why don't thank you
look at that it did it did the mean to
one
alright we're recording is it working
god I'm so paranoid it's so scary
recording in VR am i shorter now
say it honestly am i shorter am i short
there now I will kill you I will kill
you do understand now don't do that
that's annoying I don't like that stop
shooting
are you gonna keep doing that you're
just gonna keep doing the help have a
bucket [ __ ]
[Music]
you pathetic
die die we don't be back yes it was that
was [ __ ] crazy that was [ __ ]
awesome holy [ __ ] guys alright I first
try
boomer say step alright okay I thought I
missed that I miss something
oh god I'm gonna dying it's gonna squish
me oh god this is bad this is real bad
what do we do oh god I can't move I'm
froze oh we're fine they were fine
open yeah hey my hand well let's think
about Alex he's on a fortune moving at
three bars and health plus he's a
fugitive
you don't think on one leg there's
obstacles to a direct path you know
we're going up to the thing that's so
cool I should be yes you're the one he
hit it towards dangers we should be the
ones worried about you
I'm not the Fred who wants some who
wants some who wants some come get some
there has to be an upgrade station that
I miss because I feel like I haven't
seen one in forever
maybe it's done here
ah
for some reason it's harder to pick up
items that are further
I mean closer English help me that's a
big-ass drawer dude if I ever saw a big
drawer
do you think there's something
underneath the bed some bedbugs alright
you can't fault me for not looking all
behind the mirror tap button twice to
toggle burst fire thank you
burst fire burst fire I don't think so I
don't think so I think you know it's the
answer I really didn't have to get hit
there I'm [ __ ] around too much
how did they put these vases everywhere
not make them smashable huh valve huh I
gave you so much credit in the beginning
Oh finally
Alex I don't know if you noticed but
[ __ ] half of them aren't wearing
shirts can you put it in your backpack
thank you
can you not look look away [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's important to wash your hands
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you happy birthday to be birthday oh oh
I know I didn't know that did you did
you know that where's the money huh
where's my [ __ ] money huh you know I
don't like to wait where's my [ __ ]
money
Oh
smackle house Phillips what's up [ __ ]
just sure
all right check if it's safe applause
all right oh I should've done the
spider-man jump there I didn't I didn't
commit I don't know why I didn't I don't
know why I didn't commit Jack to throat
me he's so sweet he said my half-life
videos are great I actually was gonna
give Jack a shout out because Jack is
really good at doing Let's Plays I'm not
so if you're looking for a good less
place of half-life check out Jack's I
really mean that
cuz I know I know I mess around too much
for people's flavor I just can't help
myself you know what I mean
you know what I mean I just skedaddle
I just skedaddle I can't help it I can't
help it's too fun
don't Oh I mean do come on why your mu
your immune muhfucka
never yes Queen quick quick quick quick
quick
going going going going going
Queen my lower my queen my queen let me
please I'm not worthy I'm a simple I am
yet my fellow eager please
that's right naughty naughty I'm still
new number one right I'm still your
number one right that's what I thought
you thought you talked oh no it's gonna
be an explosion in the backroom gamers
bathroom bathroom learn English
I better coats to get day oh we got damn
that's some explosive diabolical I hear
Morris sir let's be careful I feel like
I missed some stuff over there let me
just check her the queen [ __ ] [ __ ] you
look good tonight which I wanna you is
there literally nothing it's there
literally nothing
all right where was I
he literally don't remember where I came
from
always there now remember oh maybe in
here I felt like there ought to be
something more but okay I guess not
alright who wants some
and I'm coming
yes yes hey hey I'm not talking to you
I'm not talking to you ooh I'll take
those
you could double pump that makes no
sense they making no sense did you guys
see something am I going crazy
Jesus goddamn that's a long way down
mother yeah no yeah no I'm serious
thank you no I need that any day any day
any day ah I know I'm oh my god oh my
god I'm alive I'm alive
all right let's be careful I will shoot
any bird any oh nice nice excellent
come on come on baby come to me come to
me don't be scared
yes
hey [ __ ] catchy no god damn it
shut up all right I'm in
what were you doing in there what were
you doing in there who smack Oh smack
all come you're all stuck dude it
doesn't know he's dead what in the world
is this game dude where you get your
nails done go let me wash your girl oh
god what did I do
however damn you girl you're nasty huh
he owns you dirty the hell man what you
up to huh
what's your job uh you to buy you make a
lot of money doing a ya see ninja make a
lot of money yeah you heard of that
booty pound [ __ ] love him
I [ __ ] love him yeah
getting tired of this place it's boring
I don't like it I want to go somewhere
else come I come I come I come I come it
to me sure you do you like that oh my
god how'd I miss Point Blank [ __ ]
range huh
how does that happen
that's fine all right hold up more I
might I'm spinning around too much girl
you look good you want something useless
to chew on all right we're getting close
to the end here we're getting close
we're getting really really really close
okay all right I suppose in here then
don't do it this is a creepy-ass
corridor a man hole that the game is
lagging that we're still good
there's no handles on the doors right
spare percent oh no no
that was dope take a wiggle what is that
the hell is that hey hey I should have
saved that need Oh No oh god I love that
Joseph's granddad or whatever oh my god
the hell happened your mom has breast
cancer oh my god Oh what happened
all right Oh God
you scared me so much hold up is her
food ready okay I'm coming don't ever do
don't do that you can't do that
how long have you been recording